Hi, I'm Alex Pasek,
and I clean drains.
Today we're going to
look at a few drains,
and I'm going to show
you how to clean them.
When a drain is clogged,
the obvious problem
is that it backs up
and water doesn't drain,
which can cause flooding,
which can lead to the drain
backing up further
down its run,
where it's even harder
to get a clog out of.
So regular maintenance of
drains is really important
to avoid those
types of things.
Here we've got
a basin drain.
The water runs through
the grate on the top,
falls down into this basin,
and the water that falls in
brings with it any
of the dirt or sand
or whatever else it
picks up with it
into that basin.
So the first step I do
is I pop off the grate top.
I see that it's
very backed up
with the soil and sand,
so I start digging,
just trying to expose as
much of the drain as I can.
I see that there's
the exit pipe,
and around it is a lot of
roots mixed in with the sand.
So I start to kind of
break away at those,
eventually getting down
and pulling out the
roots from the pipe.
I get further down
into the basin,
and finally hit the bottom,
where the roots
are all coiled,
and I'm able to pull
out those roots
all in a few big pieces.
And then I give the drain
a quick scrape-out
and clean,
and then pop the
lid back on,
and that's good to go.
So, French drains
are typically
at the bottom of a
sloped driveway.
And the reason for that is
if the driveway
is on a slope
and the house is at
the end of the slope,
water will continue on the
slope and end up in the house.
So the French drains
are put there
as a way to divert the
water away from the house.
First, I'm just going
to take off the top.
I already can see that
there's quite a lot
of debris in here.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is just get my shovel and
start digging it out.
There's all types of different
creatures living in here.
Some worms, some bugs.
The debris is made
up mostly of soil
and sand and pine needles,
so everything
that's good for
blocking a drain
is in there.
Then I'm going to start
cleaning the pipe
that exits this drain.
And obviously this
is important because
no matter how clean
the drain is,
we're relying on that pipe
to bring out the water.
And I don't stop
doing that until
either I can sort
of see light
through the end of that pipe
or until I'm pretty certain,
by shoving
something in there,
that it is now cleaned out.
And then I get out
the pressure washer,
give the whole chamber and
the top of it a clean,
which just allows
for better flow
and a nicer
appearance as well.
After that, I pop
the grates back on,
and we're looking at
a clean French drain.
It's important
to keep an eye
on the level of debris
in French drains.
They can fill up
quite quickly,
even in the drier months.
It's easy just to
look in and see, OK,
there's a little bit
of stuff in here.
I can no longer see the
concrete base of the drain.
It's probably time
to open it up
and just see how
deep this is
and then give it a
quick sweep out.
These chambers are
fairly simple to clean,
and it's quite easy
just to get a shovel
and start scooping
that debris out.
This drain didn't have any
roots growing into it,
which is a good sign.
That means that this debris
hasn't probably been
there too, too long.
It's probably only been
there a couple years, maybe.
Once all of that muck is
scooped out of there,
I took the opportunity,
while it was all open
and free of debris,
to actually give
it a good clean.
So I got a pressure
washer there
and was able just to
clean off the sides
of the drain.
And that just allows
for better flow
through the whole drain,
as the water often
comes in at the side,
not actually right
through the top,
so the smoother the surface
for the water to go in
just allows a better
all-over flow for the drain.
I would say, you know,
don't be afraid to
open your drains
and take a look in there.
It's not so scary.
It's probably nothing
you can break in there.
Really, they are
quite simple.
Generally just chambers
that fill up with soil.
No harm in opening them
up and starting to dig.